There is a stunning double standard that I
want to talk about today with this idea of
leave the USA if you don't like it, which
Donald Trump has started talking about more
and more lately. And at the same time, Donald
Trump has a different message for immigrants
from other countries where he says, no, no,
no. If there are problems in your country,
if there are things you don't like in your
country, you shouldn't come to the u s you
should stay there and fix those problems.
So let me reset this for you. So we all know
what I'm talking about here. I told you last
week that Donald Trump's latest slogan, love
it or leave it about people who don't like
things that are happening in the United States
is straight out of the KKK as 1970s playbook.
There were billboards in all sorts of places
where the Ku Klux Klan would use this slogan
in the 1970s in North Carolina also in other
states, love it or leave it. And it was about
being against communism. And I forget the
other intention that it had, but it was relevant
to the politics at the time that the KKK was
getting behind. Trump has adopted this slogan
and this idea now, and he's increasingly taking
the approach that if the ethnic minority,
democratic congress, women or whoever aren't
pleased with something that's going on in
the United States, they should just move to
another country that they like better.
They don't need to try to change the United
States. Love it or leave it. If you don't
like it, then just go somewhere else. But
then at the same time, when Donald Trump is
faced with the reality that we have many immigrants
who are coming to the United States fleeing
their home countries seeking asylum, his view
becomes completely different. Oh No, they
shouldn't have fall under the [inaudible]
love it or leave it umbrella. If they don't
like what's going on in their home country,
they should stay there and fix the problems
of their country so that then their country
would be better and they would no longer be
interested in coming to the United States.
That's exactly what people are trying to do
here in the United States. Right? Trump says
immigrants should fix their home countries
rather than go to a different country. It
would be immigrants to the United States.
Let me say it a different way. Foreigners
should stay in their home countries and try
to fix them rather than coming to the United
States. Well, that's what people in the United
States are trying to do. And you're telling
them, if you don't like what's going on here,
go somewhere else. When we call for changing
our immigration policy, we're trying to fix
our country to say, if you don't like it,
go somewhere else. As antithetical to what
this country was founded on. We want to change
the healthcare system here so that we can
live here and have healthier people and people
who can work in ways that are not impacted
by whether they're going to lose health insurance,
a mediocre as it might be by quitting their
job. We're staying in our country and trying
to change it, but in those cases, Trump's
advice is go to Europe or go to some other
place that has the healthcare system that
you're describing.
No, this is the entire point. We want to improve
the country. We're not trying to bail out
and go somewhere else. So this fundamentally
comes down to yet another one of these double
standards. I know that why even mention it
at this point, the Republican Party under
Trump has become completely immune to double
standards. No one could possibly support Trump
if they cared about double standards. So we've
got to go beyond that. This is about how politics
works. Okay. If we allow this narrative of
if you don't, uh, if you have so many complaints,
why don't you just leave? If we allow that
to become valid political discourse, we are
allowing one of the fundamental roles of politics
to be perverted. The reason people vote in
elections, the reason we have elections is
so that if you're not happy with what's taking
place here, you can change it.
Okay? There are so many ideas that this president
pushes that are fundamentally anti American.
We've talked about most of them, threats to
the press recently saying he would take help
from Russia or China in 2020. Sure. Why not?
The way we're treating asylum seekers, it's
all anti American, but one of the most anti-American
ideas that's been flowing out of this white
houses, collective mouth is the idea that
if you don't like what's happening here, you
should leave and go elsewhere. There is nothing
more American than being an activist for the
type of country you want to have. And I'll
go even further. Donald Trump's spent Barack
Obama's presidency slamming Obama about all
the things that were wrong with the United
States of America. He ran on making America
great again by changing it from Obama's America
by his own logic, right? He should be leaving
if he doesn't like it.
He didn't like it under Obama, he should've
left instead, he ran for president and won.
So of course it's a talking point. Of course
it's ignorant rhetoric from the White House.
Love it or leave it, but it is so fundamentally
anti American that we can't give them an inch
on this one. Don't like it. Leave no [inaudible].
If you don't like it, you try to change it.
Just like Trump did in 2016 just like we've
been doing for hundreds of years. So it's
really important. Help me on this one. We
cannot allow the love it or leave it idea.
I know the slogan is cartoonishly a KKK slogan
revitalized by Donald Trump as he has done
with so many nationalists a slogans and mottoes
over the over the last couple of years. I
understand that the idea of it cannot be allowed
to infiltrate American politics because it
is so destructive and so anti-American. Make
sure you give us a like on Facebook at facebook.com/david
Pakman show, uh, approaching 100,000 likes
on Facebook, which the kids these days tell
me no longer matters. The kids are all off
Facebook now.
Uh, but apparently to people my age, Facebook
is still sort of cool. So anyway, give us
like their quick break back after the